hello everyone and welcome to a
wonderful game from the super chess
league organized by samaraina and the
chess base india it's abhijit gupta
versus hikaru nakamura and as you might
have already heard it's a very
controversial game but
aside from all the controversy the game
itself is actually very enjoyable and uh
well just very rich in itself so without
further ado let's check it out and see
uh why it's so enjoyable so gupta with
the white pieces opens with d4 we have
knight if six by hikaru
c4 and e6 we have knight to f3
and now uh c5 striking against the
center here we have d5 and now b5 hikaru
goes for the blumenfeld gambit uh
similar to the bengal gambit only you
you have the inclusion of knight uh
on f3 and this e6 pawn so it's a little
bit different in the bengal you can just
capture on b5 then capture on a6 if
white plays a6 uh but here not really
here if you capture black just gets a
very nice center he'll already played e6
and he's ready to capture on d5 so maybe
not the the greatest of options uh
bishop to g5 is the usual reply here and
now e captures on the 5c captures and
the d6 with e3
and now uh the the most common move here
is a6 uh also possible is queen to a5
this has been played in a few games but
he carol plays bishop to d7 uh and it is
now as of move seven that we have a
completely new game uh so let's see how
gupta continues we have knight to c3
uh the b5 pawn is now nicely defended so
uh you don't have to worry about it
after you play a6 of course the bishop
also helps with that uh and now a4 uh
this is a very very good reply to
hikaru's bishop to d7 because the pawn
prevents the knight from going to c6 you
can't go to d7 you can't go to a6 so a
capture sun b5 is already a threat as
the rook on a8 is undefended so b4 can
be played but here knight to e4 is just
super annoying there is no way to avoid
white ruining your uh king's king side
uh even if bishop to e7 you can still
just capture and now if bishop captures
we're gonna pick up this pawn with check
and if pawn captures you already just to
ruin black's king side but here hikaru
has b captures on a4 and this is a a
very good move even though it doubles
your pawns here and now you have access
to the a5 square with the queen you
don't have to worry about rook covering
that square and now knight to e4 doesn't
really do anything if knight to e4 we
simply move the queen queen a5 check and
there's not a worry in the world we're
either going to capture the knight or
white has to go back with the knight to
block check so instead after a b
captures an a4 bishop to e2 preparing
the castle hikaru does the same and
agupta now castles and now rook to a7 by
hikaru he wants to play rook to b7 and
put pressure along the b file but also
just play this bishop to b5 after rook
to b7 to
try and consolidate his advantage on the
queen side or so-called advantage
with e4 grabbing more space in the
center and now hikaru castles with h3
and rook to b7 now preparing bishop to
b5 but also just attacking the b2 pawn
so this has to be defended queen to d2
defending the spawn and now bishop to b5
you could always capture on a4 but it
doesn't really do anything you okay
you're gonna grab the pawn back but then
the e4 pawn is weak so the knight is
very important
on seat regarding the e4 pawn so here we
have rook f to e1 and now knight b to d7
finally hikaru gets this knight into the
game bishop back to f4 we now want to
organize um
our attack on the e5 square uh so queen
to b8 guarding the e5 square and now
queen to c2 now putting uh more pressure
on the a4 pawn but also just defending
that e for pawn twice so now capturing
might even be an idea we have rook to e8
and now white no longer waits you could
wait a little bit you could play
something like bishop to d1 maybe
improve the position uh but he goes for
e5 right away and it comes with a with a
certain tactic because now hikaru
captures on e5 we have knight captures
on e5 and now you can't go and just grab
the piece for example if you play knight
captures an e5 bishop captures and queen
captures uh then bishop captures on b5
is just winning
your queen is attacked the rook here is
attacked and the best thing you can do
is simply give up the queen for a rook
and the bishop queen captures and now a
captures on b5 you get this position
where white is better but you know for a
rapid game maybe it would be a little
bit interesting you do have these three
pawns here on the queen side uh but okay
after knight captures an e5 hikaru
dodges this with bishop to d6 and now we
have knight to c6 attacking hikaru's
queen queen to c7 bishop captures and e6
queen captures and now bishop captures
on b5 we have a captures on b5 and now
we have rook captures on e8 we have
knight capture 78 and now queen to e2
going after that knight so knight to c7
and now rook to e1
and now the position is uh well the
material is equal but uh
sorry the material is not equal hikaru
is up upon but white has a very very
strong pressure here and it's not easy
for black to get his pieces into the
game so here you could grab the d5 pawn
but that's not very good if you capture
on d5 then we simply play knight
captures queen captures and we go for
this uh in the story tonight's the e7
check winning winning black's queen
so after this rook the one king the f8
was played by hikaru and now uh
of course uh such things are no longer
possible the knight is not in range to
deliver check but there is something
else white can play this was not played
in the game however uh feel free to
pause the video here and try to find a
move where white can see
could seize
incredible advantage while i give you a
couple of seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
very very difficult idea to spot and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it's knight to e4 that's the good
stuff attack the queen and force the
queen to capture the d5 pawn of course
you know the queen doesn't have to
capture the queen could just move for
example queen somewhere queen to f4
but the problem is now we have g3 and
where does the queen go to well there's
not
you don't have all that many squares and
you don't even have to play g3 you could
capture on c5 right away g3 is just if
you want to further improve your
position but even just capturing here is
enough because now if the knight
captures we play queen to e7 check king
goes back and we give up the queen for
checkmate knight captures rook captures
an e8 and this is now checkmate
so that's the problem with knights to e4
you can't move the queen but queen
captures on d5 loses also tonight to d8
attacks the rook and once the rook moves
now we play rook to d1 and you cannot
defend your knight these two squares are
covered by the knights so your only
square is f5 but now we play g4 and
that's it the queen moves we pick up the
knight we win the game
very very good stuff yeah so
congratulations to everyone who spotted
knight d for here but in the game uh
queen to e7 check was played queen
captures on e7 and rook captures on e7
attacking the knight here so knight the
e8 now the rook nicely defends the
knight and now knight to e4 but now it's
uh it's a different story here hikaru
plays rook to c7 he wants to play rook
c7 move this knight and trade off the
the rooks because this rook is uh very
strong here but also with rook to c7
you're just threatening to capture this
knight remove the defender of the rook
and pick up the rook however b4 was
incredibly strong here there's not much
white can do against a3 but it's a rapid
game uh you know keep that in mind
always uh so rook the c7 with that
threat and now uh knight to g5 going
after the f7 pawn so now uh you you have
to uh do something about that of course
now if you capture here we're first
gonna capture on f7 with check the rook
is now defended and then after the key
moves we're now going to capture here
and now white is completely winning so
here after knight the g5 hikaru played
knight d to f6 but also uh it was in
this position that hikaru received a
phone call from his stepfather and also
said someone's calling me unbelievable
uh and you know he just muted it put the
phone somewhere else and then continued
playing the game so here rook captures
on c7 was played hikaru recaptured with
the knight and now d6 this is a very
dangerous pass pawn but luckily two
knights and the king are very near that
pawn
so knight to e6 and now uh gupta just
trades we have knight captures f
captures and now knight to e5 creating a
wall here against hikaru's king but
hikaru's king is not uh your your
biggest concern here your biggest
concern is this three to one advantage
on the queen side so hikaru of course
pushes c4 uh he wants to play c3
eliminated this pawn and then just
advance his past a pawn to victory so
king f1 gupta starts improving the
position of his king now c3 of course
you have to play this now the thread is
just captures and promoting so b
captures and now a3 we have d7
threatening d8 queen uh but just king to
e7 we have knight to c6 check you have
to give up the pass pawn in order to
prevent uh hikaru's pass pawn from
reaching uh its destination so king
captures knight to be for guarding a2
and now knight to d5 uh of course white
cannot afford to trade knights so knight
to a2 and now king d6 now hikaru just
has to bring his king into the game king
e2 we have king to c5 king to d2 and now
king to c4 we have king to c2 and now b4
again you can't afford to trade because
if check of course the knights get
traded off the board and then you're up
upon of course completely winning uh
white king will have to block this pawn
somehow and in that time you will pick
up all of white's pawns on the king's
side and of course easily win the game
so after b4 we have knight to c1 but it
doesn't help we have b captures on c3
and he was in this position on mu 43
that abject gupta resigned in the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
now hikaru is completely winning he's up
two pawns and uh well let's say you play
a move somewhere we can easily just play
knight before check king moves uh for
example c or c to check king moves
knight to d3 and that's it either the
knight moves and then we promote to a
queen and the win whites knight or you
capture capture and then uh well the the
the white king cannot stop those pawns
from advancing uh and another thing if
you don't wanna trade like this you
could play knight a2 right away but then
again knight to b for
now we already said that this is
completely winning captures captures
you're up two pawns of course that's it
uh so he car won this game during the
actual game but then after the
tournament uh he uh continued streaming
he you know played
some games online did his stuff uh and
then he received the uh information that
he is actually being disqualified that
it is not allowed to pick up or not just
pick up but have any electronic devices
around you
while playing the games so maybe he
didn't consider this as this isn't like
a very serious tournament it's not a
rated one uh
so maybe
that's why he he had his phone there but
you know
the rules are rules and even though he
won the game he actually lost the game
uh so yeah that's the game uh hope you
guys enjoyed it even when you win make
sure you didn't lose uh so that's
maybe the moral of the story here i
would like to wish a very happy birthday
to patrick bolin and i would like to
thank tom darrell and nicolas see this
david kimura and john cousins for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank all for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of
everything else uh and including this
that's happening in the chess world
uh so thank y'all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your
weekend